did you hear what Jessica scre Nick oh
that's gross she was the blonde Brad
she said she wore a dental dam I don't
know you ever seen one of those I've
never seen a dental dam
yeah I've seen one I've used one on on
what a hand sandwich you're practicing
you put it on your flashlight retroflex
like with a dental dam you're respecting
it [ __ ] I don't know I know I just want
to make sure this I've had four sexual
partners I don't want to transmit
anything who knows how many people have
used you the roommate flashlight laying
a dental dam over a flashlight is like
the lonely thing that's what Jared's do
they pull out a dental dam on it that's
how you actually gets kernig we should
eating out of a ham sandwich oh that's
the grossest thing like mate Blaire some
male on there and just in a hole inside
pretty quick vertically and you put a
dental dam over a vertical ham sandwich
and just what are you doing later just
gonna practice
[Laughter]
[Music]
this time constant clown
these are Dustin phone these are just
all in my bag on my wrists all